[techno music]
♪
- NOBODY LIKES YOU, YOU GIRL.
- WELL, YOU'RE A DIFFERENT COLOR
THAN ME,
AND THAT'S BAD.
- OH, YEAH?
WELL, YOU DRESS LIKE--
- NOW HOLD ON A SECOND!
both: WHOA!
MR. T?
- NEVER MAKE FUN
OF A WAY A MAN DRESSES.
THE WAY A MAN DRESSES
IS HIS BUSINESS.
REMEMBER THAT.
WHETHER IT'S OVERALLS,
CHAINS,
OR FEATHER EARRINGS,
HOWEVER THEY DRESS,
IT'S NOT TO BE JOKED ABOUT.
I PITY THE FOOL THAT JUDGES
ANOTHER MAN'S CLOTHING.
- I'M SORRY
I JUDGED YOUR CLOTHING.
- IT'S OKAY.
[upbeat music]
- HEY, SCOUT, THERE'S A MAN
OVER THERE
WHO SAID HE'LL GIVE US CANDY
IF WE GET IN HIS VAN.
- OH, I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S A GOOD IDEA, TIMMY.
- WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF?
IS IT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
A STUPID NAME LIKE SCOUT?
- HEY!
both: WHOA! MR. T AGAIN.
- NEVER MAKE FUN
OF A PERSON'S NAME.
YOUR MAMA GAVE YOU
THAT NAME,
OR YOU MADE IT UP
FOR BUSINESS PURPOSES.
EITHER WAY, IT'S PERSONAL.
I PITY THE FOOL THAT MAKE FUN
OF ANOTHER MAN'S NAME.
MR. T'S A COOL NAME.
IT'S A COOL NAME, MR. T.
[upbeat music]
- HEY, SCOUT,
WANT TO DO SOME DRUGS?
- AREN'T DRUGS BAD?
- I DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU'RE AFRAID OF DRUGS,
WE COULD DRINK
A BUNCH OF ALCOHOL.
- YUM, THAT SOUNDS GOOD.
- WELL, GUESS WHAT,
YOUR HAIR IS STUPID.
- NEVER MAKE FUN
OF ANOTHER PERSON'S HAIR!
both: HEY, MR. T.
- A PERSON'S HAIR
IS THE ARTWORK THAT THEY PRESENT
TO THE HEAVENS.
IT'S JUST LIKE
I'VE BEEN SAYING...
[upbeat music]
♪
all: ♪ HAIR
♪ IT ISN'T FAIR
♪
♪ BEWARE
♪ PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT THEIR HAIR ♪
♪
- ♪ "H" IS FOR THE HOME
WHERE I LAY MY HEAD ♪
♪ AND I CRY
ABOUT YOUR MEAN JOKES ♪
♪ IN MY BED
♪ "A" IS FOR ANXIETY
THAT FOOLS PROVOKE ♪
♪ WHEN THEY LOOKIN' AT MY HAIR
AND THEY MAKIN' JOKES ♪
♪ "I" IS FOR I DON'T LIKE
THE WAY I FEEL ♪
♪ WHEN YOU'RE JOKIN' THAT
MY HAIRCUT DOES NOT APPEAL ♪
♪ "R" IS FOR THE REAL MEAN JOKES
YOU MAKE ♪
♪ AND THE HURTFUL
LITTLE POTSHOTS THAT YOU TAKE ♪
AND, FOR YOUR INFORMATION,
IT'S NOT EVEN A HAIRCUT.
IT'S A RARE FORM
OF MALE PATTERN BALDNESS.
YOU FOOLS!
[sobs]
[yells]
FOR REAL.
[upbeat music]